My name is Kai-Fu Lee,...
...I'm Chinese-American. I was born in Taiwan.
I am the president of Google Greater China.
I think this is a tremendous time to have this confluence of the two amazing cultures.
I feel, to be successful in this 21st century,...
...you really have to combine the Asian wisdom of perseverance, of humility...
...and along with the American characteristics of courage and proactivity.
Many Asian-Americans, I think in the past...
...have worked more on assimilating into America...
...which I think is certainly important.
But I think with the emergence of Asia,...
...it's also important, I think for the Asian-Americans that are growing up...
...not to forget their roots.
Not only is it really critical to help them become leaders of the 21st century...
...but also it will help them in their pursuit of their careers and dreams.
Because Asia is emerging so quickly, there are so many opportunities.
So, Asian-Americans really should grasp this unique opportunity.
Not just to think about the assimilation...
...but also about how to leverage the great heritage that they have.